[Música]
uma vez eu estava passeando com dois
irmãozinhos e de carro e fui levar eles
foi devolver na comunidade né
aí eu passei numa numa cozinha ali e um
brincão no carro e um deles virou pra
mim e falou que foi aqui que o nosso pai
morreu de tiro
eu vi uma criança uma vez de oito anos
de idade oito anos de idade chegou pra
mim e se orgulhando se gabando tava com
uma cápsula de fuzil estava organizando
uma o organizando um projeto de educação
numa comunidade uma vez e não sei o que
me deu vontade de sair para respirar
tomar uma água e foi na rua eu cheguei
na rua estava estava uma rodinha de
meninos crianças e adolescentes eu já
conhecia esse pessoal e eu comecei a
trocar idéia com essa galera e ver o que
estava acontecendo ali brincando e tal
eu tinha um pessoal de 15 6 anos johan
dando às criancinhas de 10 12 anos ali
ea brincadeira deles no dia foi que
essas criancinhas de 10 e 12 anos
estavam eles eles viram as crianças
fazendo sexo entre elas os homens no
meio do mato dentro da casa dos outros
eu fui visitar uma família que eu atendi
um tempo atrás e eles têm um bebezinho
de cinco anos e quando cheguei lá pra
dar um abraço nessa garotinha eu vi que
o corpo dela estava todo cheio de
feridas
o corpitcho deferida eu fui ver o porquê
que ela estava daquele jeito né e ea
resposta foi por conta de água
contaminada
estava trabalhando no outro dia recebi
uma mensagem que um chefe de família que
eu que eu atendi um tempo atrás ela ela
tinha sido espancada por um parente
alcoólatra que chegou alcoolizado e
espancou ela não quer dizer
a agente quando é inserido nessa
realidade a gente quer de fora dessa
realidade social e quando a gente é
inserido nesse nesse contexto social
começa a vivenciar essas coisas
isso isso torna a gente isso dá uma
força pra gente querer modificar essa
realidade a gente querer transformar
essa realidade e isso acontece comigo
aconteceu comigo e eu tenho certeza que
acontece com vocês se vocês fossem forem
entrar e conhecer inserir nesse contexto
social e eu tenho certeza que é o que
acontece com o governo com as ongs 11
com as empresas que são a estrutura hoje
para lidar com os problemas
socioambientais que a gente tem e é
presa do governo hoje como eu não estão
conseguindo lidar com esses problemas de
uma forma rápida de uma forma
exponencial
então quando quando a gente a gente
entende que existe um problema ea gente
não tá ganhando desse problema o
problema dos problemas somente ganhando
da gente
isso me deixou muito muito muito triste
começou ea questionar também o próprio
trabalho é porque isso não não está
adiantando o que estava acontecendo
então foi aí que eu comecei a entender o
que eu tinha feito de bom jardim
resultado social que tinha potencial
para gerar impacto social e
transformação de centenas de milhares de
pessoas
quais foram as iniciativas que eu fiz
que que realmente teve essa peça é teve
esse potencial de desenvolvimento de
pessoas e eu depois eu fui ver o caminho
é para o que a gente tinha feito de
certo e também comecei a estudar a nível
global todas as iniciativas que
realmente estavam mudando o mundo
então a gente olhando as políticas
públicas a gente olhar intervenções
sociais o que elas tinham em comum que
realmente estava dando resultado
realmente estava acelerando o processo e
estava conseguindo chegar perto de
resolver algum tipo de
sócio ambiental o ponto em comum que eu
acho que todas essas iniciativas
foi justamente é todas as intervenções
inclusive as minhas ter tido a
participação ea co criação de todos os
sistemas socioeconômicos juntos ou seja
a empresa ong governo comunidade
sociedade tô trabalhando junto para
resolver uma alça era isso que estava
estava mudando o mundo era isso que
estava resumindo é exatamente como o
grande professor de harvard e marca o
porta fala a teoria dele do chevelle do
valor compartilhado que quando a gente
trabalha no valor compartilhado entre a
ong eo empresa comunidade sociedade a
gente acelera os resultados sociais que
a gente tem
ou seja a gente consegue trabalhar em
inovação social nesse sentido é inovação
social que a gente está fazendo conta se
trata de inovação
a gente teria eu tive que entender o
porquê e como a gente conseguiu é juntar
essas forças não é juntar essa estrutura
socioeconômica luta com a causa que a
gente tá estava lutando não foi
exatamente é essa e é esse esse feeling
que dizem entender todo o processo passo
a passo que a gente deu pra realmente
juntar é empresa onde o governo e
comunidade em prol de uma causa o que
aconteceu o que a gente fez call com o
primeiro passo foi foi justamente
trabalhar nas novas economias
as novas economias dos princípios dos
valores intangíveis da abundância e
principalmente ter tudo a ver com o
afluxo o nome e 4d
quando a gente fala d 4d a gente fala
começa a trabalhar às novas economias em
quatro dimensões social ambiental e
financeira e cultural
isso tudo fez com que esses cinco passos
pra gerais e esse engajamentos das
estruturas que estão
além do problema é os problemas sociais
hoje no brasil no mundo
eles foram feitos embasado só tiro é e
serviu pra mim e se esses passos nessa
serve pra realmente alcançar resultados
sociais positivos e com certeza pode
servir pra vocês também
o primeiro passo é começar a trabalhar
na economia criativa foi o que eu
percebi já estava trabalhando na
economia criativa por si um é por falha
no negócio social negócio de impacto e
empreendedorismo social porque quando eu
tô trabalhando nesse sentido eu consigo
despertar a curiosidade e interesse das
pessoas que estão vindo ali estão vendo
o a missão social da empresa sendo feita
quando a missão só da empresa tá sendo
bem feita quando a gente entra dentro de
uma comunidade quando a gente conhece
uma realidade diferente ea gente mostra
isso
a gente trabalha no primeiro valor
intangível que é o amor que é o primeiro
passo a gente trabalhar mostrando o amor
preciso então quando eu comece a mostrar
depoimentos de de crianças tendo orgulho
que fazem parte de comunidade chefes de
família mostrando a família união que a
família tem a própria comunidade sendo
mobilizada para criar intervenções ou
também projetos de melhoramentos do
bairro melhoramento da qualidade de vida
e do bem estar ali
quando a gente começa a mostrar isso
tudo pra sociedade às vezes a sociedade
tá tá achando que existe é invisível
quando a gente começa a mostrar os
mecanismos de veículos de comunicação
mostrar o trabalho social isso começa a
atrair essas pessoas que querem
trabalhar nesse sentido
atrair pessoas atrair as pessoas boas
que vão lidar com essa situação com a
gente ea gente acaba atraindo empresas
que querem ajudar a gente acaba tendo as
portas abertas para entrar no governo a
gente tinha começa a trabalhar lado a
lado com as ongs com os líderes
comunitários com a comunidade e isso
tudo começa a criar um movimento quando
começa a atrair esse processo e as
pessoas começam a conhecer o que é o
amor sente viver o que é amor dentro da
comunidade
a gente começa a trabalhar no segundo na
segunda economia no segundo passo que a
economia compartilhada onde essas
pessoas vão começar a compartilhar esses
valores essa causa
essa luta quando a gente começa a
compartilhar essa luta e ea e essa luta
se torna uma luta em comum essas causas
que a gente identificou se torna uma
causa em comum a gente começa a entender
e sentir empatia porque o que aquela
criancinha com o corpo todo ferido que
eu falei no início poderia ser sua filha
seu pai poderia ter sido morto a tiros
perto da sua casa por conta de de
tráfico de drogas
sua mãe poderia ter sido espancada pelo
seu tio chegou cola em casa então isso
tudo gera um engajamento quando as
pessoas entram nesse e nesse contexto
social e sugere o engajamento e aí que
começa o fluxo é aí que começa a força
para criar o desejo de criar soluções
para mudar a realidade daquelas pessoas
e em conjunto é muito mais fácil quando
a gente está na iminência de mudar de
querer fazer de realmente ir pra são a
gente já começa a trabalhar na economia
colaborativa quando a economia
colaborativa chega quando as pessoas e e
e essa estrutura sócio econômico se unem
por uma causa aí que a mágica acontece
porque porque a solidariedade a gente
consegue com esse caminho o despertar a
solidariedade das pessoas é onde o ato
de agir vai chegar vai acontecer ou seja
aqui nós vamos planejar e executar junto
as intervenções necessárias para a causa
que a gente achou para a causa que move
a gente então quando a gente começa a
criar essas soluções destas soluções mas
a sair do papel e começam a atender uma
família duas 3 200
a gente começa a ter resultados sólidos
começa a gerar realmente dignidade para
essas pessoas para esse contexto social
que a gente vem trabalhando junto então
quanto mais dignidade a gente gera
é mais a gente vai começar a trabalhar
na economia de muito valor na economia
de motivá lo é onde os valores das
quatro dimensões social é a ambiental
financeira e cultural são entregues em
rede
essa estrutura é beneficiada ou seja
todo mundo ganha
essa é a base da nova economia aqui os
resultados vão começar a ficar sólido
porque aqui quando todo mundo ganha
quando todo mundo ver os benefícios que
a união está causando para todos
a gente consegue se manter na causa
a gente consegue fazer é com que esses
resultados se tornem a médio prazo se
tornem constantes um ano dois anos de
resultados social e de entrega e
dignidade cidadania de intervenções
sociais com sucesso
quanto mais resultados social a gente
tem mais sólido esse processo fica mais
perto do quinto e último passo a gente
tá que é exatamente o impacto
exponencial é onde tudo acontece é onde
esse modelo acelera o impacto social a
longo prazo com resultados sociais de
curto e médio bem feitos sólidos porque
quando a gente tem um impacto social
a gente já tá causando transformação ea
gente tem 17 opções de transformação e
causa para a gente lutar pra gente
reconhecer que a gente se inserido hoje
a onu disponibiliza ferramentas e e e
trabalhos bem feitos para represar
intervenções nesse sentido e com um
modelo a gente consegue acelerar e bater
a meta da onu tentar resolver cada
problema até 2030 de uma forma escalável
de uma forma exponencial
e é justamente esse modelo esse último
passo de 5º pasco que vai gerar
transformação em massa que vai mudar a
vida de dezenas centenas milhares de
pessoas
é onde há onde vai vai acontecer a
sustentabilidade do ciclo que quanto
mais impacto social e pactos policial
gente gera tu mais transformação +
mensuração a gente tem mais dados mais
números
a gente chega na sustentabilidade do
ciclo que é exatamente há a idéia de que
as economias se abrem e que entra dentro
da espiral só os sentimentos que são
exponenciais só o sentimento que tem
valores intangíveis que é o que vai
gerar transformação necessária quando a
economia sai daê ficam do lado de fora
a gente entende quanto mais impacto
social a gente mostrar mais amor a gente
vai gerar mais pessoas mas mais mas é
partes interessadas vão sentir parte do
processo
então quanto mais amor a gente mostra
com o impacto social com um trabalho bem
feito com iniciativas é de bom resultado
mas as pessoas são atraídas ou seja mais
empatia gente a gente entrega mais
empatia é feito nesse processo quanto
mais empate a gente tem mais pessoas
sentindo botão no lugar no próximo mais
solidariedade ou seja mais pessoas vão
ir pra são vão me vão fazer os projetos
acontecerem com mais projetos
acontecerem mais dignidade a gente
entrega então quanto mais dignidade a
gente entrega a palavra chave d se
decidisse espiral é confiança
quanto mais dignidade pressa para o
público alvo que está tendendo para a
causa que atendendo quanto mais unidades
a entrega você gera confiança nessas
pessoas
quanto mais confiança gera essas pessoas
está atendendo maiores as suas chances
de alcançar o impacto social impacto de
uma forma acelerada e esse modelo ele só
é é só efeito ele só pode ser realizado
quando a gente trabalha nas novas
economias
quando a gente faz um parâmetro que
demostra economia a economia
hélia neco nome que a gente está
acostumado porque é uma economia base da
escassez é uma economia base dos valores
tangíveis
a gente consegue entender que quando uma
pessoa ela ela não precisa de de
perdigão e quando ela ganha é o outro
não precisa perder então fica uma
economia base da competitividade
quando a gente fala da economia nova a
gente fala justamente da da economia
baseada na abundância e não a escassez
uma economia onde todo mundo consegue
gerar os seus valores intangíveis e não
acaba eles surgiram no infinito
então o o holo ter king se ele tivesse
vendo hoje na nossa na nossa sociedade
ele não estaria tão alto assim porque os
bons estão falando alto né hoje os bons
estão aqui estão reunidos ea tecnologia
que está proporcionando esse processo é
com a tecnologia a gente consegue juntar
quem tem vontade de fazer acontecer
quem tem tempo e quem tem conhecimento
colaborativo
então cada um de nós aqui se escolheu
uma causa para lutar juntos nós vamos
fazer muito barulho ou seja o nosso eco
vai ser muito maior e todos nós podemos
mudar o mundo
obrigado
[Música]